[Applause]
all right let's wrap up the hour with
the story perfect for the holidays this
is what I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
liking so New York City gets crazy busy
this time of year especially here in
Midtown nuts mobike even it's crazy uh
that's probably why some woman
accidentally photobombed this family
while they were filming themselves doing
a little holiday kickline in front of
Radio City Music Hall yeah I'm not even
sure she realized what was going on
actually um okay let's get a little
closer look let's see who oh yep that's
[Laughter]
me I I didn't
see uh that was me I am the one who
ruined a perfect family video um it's
only of course I did um it's only gotten
like two million hits on social media
cuz they're like who's that tool
um I apologized online but I did ask
them to dial in so I could personally do
it cuz I didn't see them anyway we have
fiance's Mark and Billy calling in from
Los Angeles and Billy's family Denise
Rachel Sue Cheryl and brillan in
Connecticut what's up
y'all I
mean let me just look I can explain okay
I was walking with my friends and family
I had to approve something I had had my
in ears in you can't see but I had in
ear in I was approving something for the
show and all of a sudden on my front no
one was walking with me and I was like
what and then when I looked it looked
like you were performing at a wall there
was no camera I did not see a camera and
I was like these people are nuts I was
like what are they doing and I never saw
the camera and then I literally walked
away and looked at Trisha was with me
and I was like that's going to end up
somewhere I'm sorry anyway hello welcome
to the
show
I just felt like I needed to apologize I
didn't realize what was happening anyway
you were all visiting New York right you
were why what was happening so Billy and
I visit um Connecticut every year for
Christmas and we started doing early
Christmas last year so you know the
chaos like you were saying Midtown is so
busy there travel is crazy so we started
doing early Christmas and we actually
never sto in New York which is crazy so
this is all like Kismet so we met up
with niece and everybody in the city and
um it was her daughter our niece Avery's
16th birthday so we're doing a little
scavenger hunt and the first clue
prompted us to go to Radio City to
perform this kick line and I was like I
have no idea how we're going to prove to
these people that we did a kick line so
um we had f it yeah so I set my camera
up on this little like fire hydrant type
thing no one could see the camera I was
like why are you performing in a brick
wall y'all I keep
going
so I set it up on this little sewer pipe
thing and we backed up to do our
kickline and then lo and behold you just
stumble right into the video do a quick
Double
Take so S no there's no need to the
thing is like it made our video made our
holiday like it was so special it
couldn't have been better literally we
couldn't have I would have been in the
zone I would have joined honestly I'm
that individual you but we didn't even
notice it was you till after when Denise
said something I know Denise you're the
one who noticed me was trying to be on
Incognito so I didn't I didn't recognize
you but then you said actually I heard
you say oh my gosh I didn't even notice
the camera and like I mean your voice is
kind of iconic so the second I heard it
I was like uh but it took a little while
to register because I was not expecting
that at all and then you walked by and I
was like guys I think that was Kelly
Clarkson and they were like what and
then we pulled up the video and there
you are wait and I just I want to come
back to
something because you have the coolest
family ever I'm totally going to make my
family do a scavenger hunt that is so
cool I or may join yours again I don't
know whichever one comes first um
congratulations on being the coolest
family ever that is the coolest
tradition I love that I'm so sorry i r
your video but it made for a very funny
moment um next time I will keep my head
up New York and pay attention uh thank
you everyone I'm liking your post right
now and that's not all our season one
partner pilot pin makers of friction and
goto race pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to make your holidays even brighter
so they're giving y'all $1,000 to make
your next visit to the city extra
special I will try not to photo vomit
and if I do I will join anyway thank you
all so much and thank you to all our
guests this hour Zack jery alen White
Harris Dickson Stanley Simons Ali Brook
Dina Jane Christian McBride Alissa
Walker yall have a great day if it's not
change
[Applause]
[Music]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home